let's see that's the final
that was another idea that was the first
idea that's a massive time for table or
something yeah she concepts of the
articles yeah so that's when I got the
chicks around you when I read the
articles I thought some there's a lot of
different stuff going on it's not quite
fitting together to me it was like too
much in my head for anything that's what
would it
you know there's loads of stuff and
these all represent different possible
methodologies and different forms of
knowledge and about you know
schizophrenia but it's all got to fit in
there to my about don't seem to fit
together and turn so that bits of
scientific knowledge which don't quite
fit together which i think is probably
true in general off scientific knowledge
this is quite fit together you see I
thought those jigsaw bits in because you
can get some olfactory hallucinations
and gustatory once but meaning
technically it's all supposed to happen
in the head I mean I don't know the
lines these well I sort of well there's
a simple explanation I find it very
relaxing to do that Glines but there's
also you I mean I think there's it's
sort of there's all those signals and
information strands and like spiders
webs all over the place and sometimes
you're tapping into them and as if you
can they're coming out of your head but
also going into your head it's it's it's
almost like a a signal overload so it's
like you know caught in this incomplete
network of secret invisible signals
which are not secret or visible to me so
that's I suppose it's a bit like that
but there's also than the simple
explanation I find it very calming to do
you